and we are live welcome to the
announcement show that's never it right
lord Cognito here with my co-host with
co most as you already know Lord addicts
so um and speaking with a few people in
a lot attic we felt it would be right to
actually make some announcements tell
people what's going on with the future
of the channel and everything like that
I mean obviously if you have been living
under a rock and not paying attention to
the ILP Twitter feed listen which is
probably the case yeah it was probably
gay it's been a lot of movin and shakin
goin on with your iron Lords podcast we
want to talk about that and you know
first off just thank everybody you know
um for supporting us from the very
beginning you know it's a small Channel
you know being Destiny's focused and um
I'll never forget you know a lot attic
the young wolf came up to me is just
like look man you know we play destiny
so much and you have someone's fun
together and we talk games all the time
you know would I be interested in you
know jumping in the YouTube scene and um
at first it was something that I like I
don't know you know but um as I watched
him in his channel and gaming out of
Channel and watch him grow and all the
little successes he's had and stuff like
that got the itch
so um yeah man that when we started this
I on launch thing and it was it was
pretty much just destiny only and um you
know it grew it grew and people really
respected our opinions when it came to
all the games and systems and stuff like
that so you know first of all this is
for y'all you know the people who are
day ones who's always been in a chat
with us always just been talking destiny
everyone who's ever came on the show you
know we wanted to thank you all because
um you know you're the guys that we
actually speak to so yeah man obviously
uh we are made a deal emerge with the
inner circle Network so um there's gonna
be a lot of our content is gonna be
there primarily our livestream so
generally when Sunday happens which
Church we we go over there and we're
gonna be watching it from that channel
so make sure you got follow the inner
circle you know a bunch of great guys
over there you know a lot of them are
friends that we've known for a long time
you know I could tell you you know from
e3 and stuff like that and just meeting
everybody and it's just a cool group of
guys with a great vision and they're
growing your own the same mindset so um
yeah you know just one of those things
you want to let the fans know what's
going on I'm gonna let Lord addict talk
a little bit I've been rambling and then
we also talked to you some lots of stuff
going on the future
I mean you pretty much said it
everything there is really the state you
know in all sense you could have did
this by yourself but we felt like you
know we respect you guys more to have
than just one person talking so and why
I'm here the co blokes
yeah so just just for the record you
know the IOP channel is not going away
all right so that's the first thing like
we're gonna still keep your channel
we're gonna do our live streams you know
I said on Sunday on the inner circle
Network so check for us there so if you
don't see it we're still gonna put the
episodes eventually on the IOP channel
mostly mostly mostly after the fact
almost as an archive also we want to let
you guys know obviously Sunday is the
Lord's Day
but um football becomes a head of the
Lord that's gonna be in Val
so yeah you definitely you know what to
be on the lookout for a day move it's
probably seasonal right there's our
football season ends we'll move that
back to our normal day we're just trying
to in transition with that you know same
thing with the audio I know like I said
a lot of you guys follow us on iTunes
and stuff like that and SoundCloud we're
up on that you know for right now those
things will stay the same we're gonna
eventually we're still in a
transitionary period with that we'll
keep you up to date as far as where to
get that information but um yeah man you
got some school stuff going and um
actually got a a big guest tomorrow so
that's gonna debut with our inner circle
debut
you know look out we got my man hip-hop
gamer you know following him for a while
so we gonna give him that uh royal
treatment you know roll out the red
carpet like the Lord's do
yeah all right Thank You Man getting
getting me into this game and uh now the
future's looking bright we got smoke
some stuff cooking up or anything else
you want to say to the people not really
feed a man a few words
[Laughter]
there's any additional questions
whatever but um that's pretty much
random we made a live stream okay no I'm
no Saturday night and everything and
everybody's you know enjoying the day
but what have you got home you say
that's pretty much what it is as far as
the future to channel and stuff like
that so um like I said don't think that
you know this is going away it's just
like I said a new beginning in future
and all the exits there are people of
the Jets take aggravated it's like on
with the show
Knight's Tale reference Oh requires in
there all right Thank You Man so for
those who just joined Game Boy Wayne
using he's one of our day ones you know
say switch gang I see you you look I
your II know the moderator moderating
this thing yes it but um yeah man so
just like I said you don't know the
channel start going away we're gonna be
doing live streams you know pretty much
on the inner circle network so make sure
you guys subscribe you know over there
content will be over there you know but
be sure to be sure to go into this uh
this live stream if we have enough time
we might let you guys ask a pop some
questions if we have enough time our
song like I said get your questions
ready you know saying with that reason
[Laughter]
also make sure we also be planning on
attic that's what you got talk to the
people we are planning on on on the ILP
channel we're probably gonna do a gangs
calm reaction thing right because games
come tomorrow it's gonna be a big one at
3:00 so we still debating if we're gonna
do it during or armed right after the
show for that war reaction right we're
at it I'm thinking about doing a you
know recording not live-streaming the
reaction and just putting a montage
together because the suck the hawk gets
announced I want to be I want the live
reactions from everyone but if you know
they come out to be like it's the
pre-orders route if it goes like that
then you know clearly I posted nothing
you've got a lot more faith about this
game big good idea red dragon posted did
you not talk to me exactly remember what
it was called something you know this
this happens three or four times a year
so you can't really take into
consideration a whole whole lot the back
window you said the logos fight oh yeah
we got a lower King on the March
merch is coming y'all gonna get them
shirts them had trust me we owned
everybody we've heard positive feedback
on the logo
preciate ya with German retailer lists
new Xbox one game code name Hollywood
$60 Tata release state 2017 interested I
think I mean it's too cool I don't know
why you know it's whatever they're even
really much we can do about that because
I want a t-shirt Frodo
is that Bob Frodo my day was I feel good
now good photos in the Jag I'm free she
ate you it I said I don't like I said
you know where to catch us you know the
movement you know saying is moving in
increments which game
yeah is that Frodo's my destiny range
since this real live man talk anyone in
this comment section play splatoon's
multiplayer like I just I'm I allegedly
felt defeated yesterday like I never
felt like that in a multiplayer game
like I'll be going out to the middle of
the field you know I felt like I felt
hot [ __ ] when I got my roller so rolling
down the road and like I see like
grenade like like these little platforms
that's like a grenade and it just
explode okay
it's like someone got some weird
grenades though that's cool go on
there's so much hovering with like these
these little they're hovering with these
guns what is it that dead so then okay
so they're not go over there and
someone's in this bubble like this
little like you know the bubble thing
you know rolling around in it beside him
and he explodes and kills me I'm like
I'm done he picked those four - so you
said to Adam maybe you could have my
baby if that's the case they need to get
their like rankings when I did look I
was playing nothing but level 30s and
higher and there might be one or two
level three or four see that the problem
with that is is they unlock everything
by levels yeah so they're gonna have
things people yeah at a disadvantage
from the jump they don't need to put the
level threes with it oh shut out the
recording unit Chet I'm not watching a
man in this game right now I'm not
interested in brian hoyer right now
females of nine is right but I would get
to that we're good you know we'll get on
xbox live and talk to each other while
we play because you know that's the only
logical place to do it
Frodo Aussie you heard me now go Broncos
[Laughter]
time out there drew oh hey know some
sports yeah but you just stopped out QB
but it's just like right now I really
want what's the Redskins quarterback
from Brad no because I think Raptors the
right reference well I know one /
today telling its jury no Frodo vodopad
oh yeah that's the tomb stuff they gotta
get that together yeah we gonna wrap
this thing up soon but again you know
think everyone your cousin's thank you
Kirk Cousins thank you McClane your nose
um yeah when I wrap this thing up man
but again everybody for the support or
day ones you know I mean it was dead we
just little fledgling no destiny channel
and talking at you know stuff and all
the guest has come on you know just a
small Channel people just showed us
tremendous love the ten dogs the
practiced cactus hd's the upon toises
you know the mean income and you know we
got a speedy bunches I miss him actually
he put some I was coming out to Jim and
he's posting like these cooking recipes
of cheesecakes and I'm like brah that's
why I don't see that work it buddy buddy
I don't see you in a gym no voice you
know kickbacks abandon all hope all I
hear about is these cheesecakes you look
good I'm gonna get a Texas or something
you shadow also to the original Lord to
man books on a cheesecake bag a little
tiny cheesecake you know ed you know my
weaknesses man that's one thing I'm a
savage made that I will fall off the
wagon which is that bad anyway let's
read this figure we were going on but
not thank you again thank everyone for
listening you know we're not posting up
and like I said check us out tomorrow
Sundays 1 p.m. we have the legendary
hip-hop game it's gonna be it's gonna be
a movie you know tall game and we're
gonna get into a mush on the Royal
Treatment work it what's that what do
you think thumbnail we should use for
this video just just have a big picture
of anchorman with his thumb up
and on that note catches in a circle
Network - well make sure you so all
right you know face